regardez un concept de véhicule qui
vient du futur qui est absolument
incroyable c'est la faradée futur 91
c'est une bagnole qui est juste
extraordinaire et le truc qui est fou
c'est que j'ai un espace de dingue pour
venir me mettre à l'intérieur regardez
la place que j'ai je suis légèrement
incurvé à l'arrière je suis super bien
et surtout le truc qui est génial c'est
que j'ai un écran intérieur qui est
complètement fou juste en face de moi on
voit pas les conducteurs qui me permet
d'avoir toute une partie pour le
divertissement regardez des films des
séries même travailler parce que j'ai
des petites webcam j'ai une caméra ici
il y a une autre caméra là ce qui me
permet de faire du travail en zoom donc
si je vais me faire une visioconférence
sur ce que je suis en bagnole et que
j'ai besoin de travailler et bien je
peux le faire si je veux regarder un
film quand je fais un bagnole je peux le
faire si je veux jouer à un jeu lorsque
je suis en bagnole je peux le faire et
la position couché légèrement à
l'arrière c'est génial parce que même
pour faire la sieste il y a absolument
incroyable et j'ai même un petit écran
sur le côté ici qui me permet de venir
piloter ma climatisation qui me permet
de piloter les massages dans le siège le
spa j'ai également une option spa et
j'ai calculé ici pour venir refermer la
porte le truc est complètement dingue et
personnellement vous êtes sûr que
j'adore la marque du véhicule
FF 91 j'aime bien leur logo que je
trouve aussi extrêmement jolie sont deux
F penchés sur le côté véhicule
totalement atypique je pense qu'on verra
jamais en France mais personnellement je
l'aime bien d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que
vous en pensez vous dans les
commentaires